- Cool.
Thanks everyone for joining.
Today we're gonna have a good discussion
on, you know, scaling AI
in the real world with AMD.
So we have an incredible panel here.
We have Arjun Raj, we
have Kasey, and Roman.
I'm gonna let them introduce themselves
and then we'll have a good conversation.
Go ahead, Arjun.
- Hi, my name is Arjun Raj.
I'm head of computational
biology currently at Somite.
I'm actually also professor
of genetics and bioengineering
at the University of Pennsylvania.
- Kasey.
- Hi, Kasey.
Head of US for Upstage AI.
- Hi, Roman Hasenback, CEO
and co-founder of Rambler AI.
- Cool.
Thank you guys for joining us today.
So I think, you know, as
you are attending re:Invent,
I think a lot of you
probably have heard AI
enough number of times, right?
So what we want to talk
about today is not just AI,
but choice in AI, right?
And how AMD's bringing
choice when you think of AI.
I think there's been a obvious, you know,
euphoria around AI, what
the possibilities of AI are,
but we also want to see how it actually
affects, you know, people,
how we actually bring it
to touch people's lives, right?
And so with the incredible
panel we have here,
we'll start, you know,
unpacking what they do,
how they're bringing AI to life,
how they're bringing AI to touch people,
and then we'll, you know,
we'll have some Q&A at the end.
So with that, Arjun, you wanna tell us
a little bit about your work?
AI and biology is like, you know,
just fascinating to just imagine, right?
It's like, it's two ends of the spectrum.
I would be like, you either
choose one or the other.
It's not like you choose both.
So you've chosen both.
So we'd love to hear,
you know, your journey
and what you plan to do.
- Yeah, well, you know,
like many journeys,
I think the problem finds you
maybe some fraction of the time.
So, you know, I can say
how I came to Somite,
and so I've been a
professor, as I was saying,
of genetics and bioengineering.
My work is really focused
around the biology of single cells.
So if you wanna talk about cells,
whether cells have free will,
just buy me a drink after and
I'm happy to talk about it.
One of the central challenges in biology
is for us to understand
how to control cells,
to tell cells what to do,
and this is one of the central missions
that Somite therapeutics is
to understand that language.
And right now I would say that, you know,
through decades of hard
biological work, we've figured out
sort of like the words, like the tokens,
but we don't know how to
string together sentences.
So if we wanted to tell,
we know kind of like the elemental units,
like the signals that
we can give to cells,
but we don't know how to
turn them into instructions
that could turn, say, a
stem cell into a muscle cell
to cure like a muscle wasting disease,
or any number of other
potential therapeutics
that are very hard to do currently.
What we're doing at Somite is generating
actually in the lab huge amounts
of data, new kinds of data
that we think will allow us
to now actually build predictive models
that allow us to solve that problem
of how to control cells
with these signals.
And we can do that, you know,
using all these new ML techniques
and powered by AMD GPUs.
- Nice.
We are super excited about that.
I mean, I personally have been working
with, you know, Frontier
research in that area,
especially given AMD's advantage
with large memory and
high bandwidth memory.
We can actually do a lot
of the, you know, discovery
in one system or one GPU, right?
And that helps facilitate
that progress in the field.
Cool.
Kasey, do you wanna give
us a little bit on Upstage?
- Yeah, of course.
After hearing what Arjun does.
Okay, so I think there's a
diversity of AI here as well.
So we're using AI to help
you, you know, help all of us,
especially the one who, you know,
where we work at a every
day, there's repetitive,
very, you know, brain-numbing workflows.
We're deploying AI to automate
all of that for enterprises
especially in the financial
service industries,
healthcare, public sector
where you think about
there's a huge, lot of
regulations or the legacies
that actually prevent you
from deploying the newest technology.
So the way that we describe ourself
is we do the unsexy work
for, you know, using AI.
So I think this is the-
- The sexy work.
- Right. Right.
But, you know, I think all
of us need AI to help us,
and I think like we ChatGPT and OpenAI,
we've all experienced what is possible
once AI is actually understand
the context and, you know,
actually help as a
co-pilot or as a companion
and help you automate
some of the workflow.
So that's where we are focused on,
and to go one level
deeper, what we identified
when we started the
company five years ago.
So we started in Korea and we went around
and met with a hundred CEOs of, you know,
Samsung, LG, and Hyundai of the world,
and ask what would be one AI use case
that you're willing to
pay whatever price it is,
if we can actually fix it for you?
And they all came back with
the most unsexy answer.
and that was the document extraction.
And like OCR, the optical
character recognition,
has been there for a while.
It's not a surprise, it's not the newest,
but it was very clear that
there was a huge limitation.
So if anyone is using OCR,
have experienced the OCR,
what happened is basically,
it is reading the documents left and right
without understanding the context
or the layout of the document.
So if you think about
there's a little bit of
changes in the layout,
or a little bit of handwriting
involved in documents,
or it's a crumbled, it's,
you know, kind of tilted,
it's kind of really throwing you off,
and that negates the purpose of automation
when you cannot get to
95% or above accuracy.
So we focused on that first
very specific use case,
and we developed our
proprietary next generation OCR,
as well as our proprietary LLM,
and that's where AMD comes in.
We're training our
proprietary LLLM Cold Solar
using AMD GPUs.
And once we marry that OCR
and LLM, what's possible now
is this becomes a
template-free extraction.
So users can come and say,
hey, I want to extract,
let's say, name, ID, address.
That information is somewhere
in this 500 page long document.
Can you find that for us?
And we can easily fetch those
information, identify it,
validate it, and extract dynamically
for very fast and cost-efficient manner,
and that's what we are
focusing on right now.
But I do believe that once we build
that data foundation for enterprises,
then we have so much opportunities
based on the foundations.
So we're also looking
into more of end-to-end
workflow automation,
but really, you know,
fixing the most unsexy job
that is actually comes with
a high willingness to pay.
That's what we do at Upstage.
- Nice.
I think, you know, it may be unsexy,
but I call it walking the last mile of AI.
You know, because the hype
and all of it is good,
but in the end, to go
touch people's lives,
you gotta go do the grunt work, right?
You want to automate those things,
and I have experienced like, even like,
rescheduling flights or something, right?
I used to dread calling,
you know, the travel agent
to go through the process,
and now it's just actually
I was talking to a person
and it got rescheduled
and then I was like, wait,
was this just automated?
And then yes, you know,
it's like passing the
Turing test for grunt work,
I think is a huge business opportunity.
So it's great that you're doing it
and doing it on AMD, right?
So that's great to hear.
Roman, you wanna introduce
yourself and Rambler?
- Sure.
At Rambler, we built
an end-to-end platform
to train and deploy vision AI agents.
Maybe to give you some background,
so I spent my entire
career on that intersection
between the real world and technology.
The previous company has
now got acquired by Apple
and is now it was kind of the
starting point for AR kid.
Apple Vision Pro.
I worked at Apple for six years
and then I decided to leave
because I saw this inflection point
where, you know, AI needs to develop
a granular understanding
of the real world,
what is going on around us in
order to be able to support us
in our day-to-day life, but
also in our, you know, at work
when you're working in
a manufacturing plant,
or for industrial processes.
So we started Rambler.
You can think of it as a system
that enables you to collect
data in the real world,
like literally how someone
is performing a task,
and then we can fine tune and
train a vision language model
on understanding how a task
is supposed to be performed,
and then we can deploy
it into the real world
and, you know, confirm
if tasks were performed
according to the standard
operating procedure
or if anyone deviated from that.
As part of that,
like the fundamental technologies,
essentially video understanding
on a granular level,
and we built kind of the
end-to-end system for that
and agnostic with regards to the hardware.
- Fascinating.
I mean, it's great to see that, you know,
we're talking about like physical AI
and vision language models,
document extraction,
and like biology and AI
all like in one, you know,
in one timeframe, right?
Like, each one of these can be, you know,
like life changing and altering
for entire generations of people.
So this is great.
So let's start with I know, Roman,
you'll have to scoot for
a flight at some point,
so whenever you want to
leave, just raise your hand.
Like, you can.
- Well, it depends on
the questions you ask me.
- Yeah, if you have any questions for him,
catch him on the way out.
But, you know, it'll be great.
You know, let's just
start with Kasey maybe.
You know, enterprise AI, right?
Like, enterprise is just huge.
What are trends that you're seeing
in terms of AI
infrastructure and, you know,
people always think that GPU poor, right?
Or you always need more GPUs or compute,
and given that you have
like that touch point with enterprises,
how do you see the world
and what do you see, you
know, from your customers?
- Yeah, love this question.
I think it actually, I wanna
fast forward to actually like,
look back when this whole generative AI
was the big shock like last year.
:Lot of enterprise's customer came to us
and say, hey, what is...
Like, this is two years ago,
and then they started doing POC
and they're was like, what
is this enterprise AI?
Sorry, generative AI.
How do I get started?
And back then the answer was
okay, there is an OpenAI,
there is an anthropic.
Huge, massive model.
You can't really take
it onto your own premise
or your own cloud environment.
So the only way to tap
into this new technology
was actually leveraging
really high compute GPU
in a major cloud provider like AWS.
And it was amazing how
some of the POC went well,
but I think there were
various reports that came out,
like, namely the MIT report that came out
like, you know, summer this year
that like 90 something percent
of the POC for enterprise
didn't get to the production.
And I think we've seen
the fair amount of those cases as well,
and really that came down to ROI.
Like, okay, this is great, it works great.
How much is it again?
Then that's where like the
conversation gets stuck,
and that's where,
going back to your
question on infrastructure,
and the software, the AI, the model side
are so, you know, all in
the same time in parallel
improved a lot to the point
that for the tedious workflow
that enterprise are trying
to achieve using AI,
you don't need this
massive frontier model.
You can actually achieve this
using much, much smaller model
that can actually feed
on CPU, not even GPU.
And that's where the conversation
kind of turned with our customers
that, like, for us, for
document extraction,
we have an OCR model that is like
not even a billion in the parameter size,
and then our model LLM is
like 17 billion parameter.
It's nicely built on a single GPU,
and then you can achieve
the same level of accuracy,
same level of performance,
and with the hardware cost that is 1/10th,
this is a no brainer, and this is a case
where you can actually productize.
So I think fast, you
know, like within a year,
we've noticed that this conversation
just rapidly changed from
POC to actual production ROI,
and now a lot of enterprises do the POC,
understand the use case,
test the capability,
look for a smaller model
that they can deploy
a lot more efficiently
on a smaller set of GPU, or
even CPU, and then deploy it,
and then actually get onto
multiple use cases like this,
and that way they can
achieve a lot more efficiency
in terms of the hardware cost
as well as the software cost as well.
- Yeah, I think that's a good point,
and also the hardware
evolution, like for example,
what we see with AMD, right?
Like, we have a pervasive
AI hardware story.
So even on our laptops, like
the laptop I carry around
is a RYZEN Max 395.
It's like 128 gigs of HBM.
Not HBM. 128 gigs of RAM.
Can run like a GPT OSS 120B,
you know, fully, right?
And that's on a laptop.
So it'll be interesting
to see as, you know,
your models kind of get to the edge,
how it enables that
intelligence at the edge,
but even though it starts from, you know,
infrastructure that's
built on MI 300, et cetera.
Arjun, on the biology
plus AI front, right?
Like, I'm fascinated as
to like, when did you,
like, you know, it's like,
because you're coming
from the biology side of things,
you're like, suddenly you find a tool.
It's like you found a hammer
and you've had all these nails
and now you're like, oh
great, I can actually do this.
Like, can you walk us through,
when did you like become a believer
in like, okay, this is a hammer
and here are the nails that
I gotta go, you know, hit on.
- Yeah, I mean, I think, well for me,
I had to sort of personally
like a Chat GPT moment
where I was like, wow, this
is really changing things.
So that was obviously
one major inflection
point for me personally,
but then just in the field
in general of biology,
I would say for the last
honestly, 20, 30 years,
a lot of it has gotten stuck.
It's hit a complexity barrier
where I think human understanding,
you know, there's massive investment
in trying to understand how biology works,
and there are a lot of
sort of very linear stories
that people had developed in science.
Like, you know, this
causes this, causes this,
and basically around sort of, you know,
the year 2000 or a little before that,
maybe even starting before that,
we just started to hit
this complexity wall
where it was like, you know,
A depends on, you know,
A1 through A200 depends
on B1 through B2000.
Like, that kind of thing.
So, you know, there were so many problems
that we've been sort of
mired and stuck with,
and now those are starting to
be solved by machine learning,
which is really remarkable.
I mean, we can now build predictive models
that could tell us how a
particular sequence of DNA
might affect how some biomolecule
worked, and in principle,
all of this was all there,
but we just couldn't pull
out the meaning from it
or pull out the predictive power
at least let's say, right?
And, you know, AlphaFold
was one huge moment
for, you know, where basically
where do atoms line up to form molecules?
I think that's just
the tip of the iceberg,
and I think, you know,
Somite is supposed to
do interesting things.
I think that'll be just
one of many, you know,
huge changes that we're gonna see
in the coming decade, let's say.
- Nice. Nice.
That's exciting.
And Roman, on the vision
language models, right?
Vision is just, I mean, it's
the amount of data is infinite.
Like, I can look at this
room in 10 different ways
and I can process, you know,
audio visual signals in different ways
like how the brain does it,
and you're trying to make sense of that
and make it accessible to
machine learning models
and also reason with that, right?
That's just, you know,
that's another step function.
Just like on the biology side,
you're just taking the physical world
into a consumable form.
So when did that click
for you and how? (laughs)
You're like, ah, okay, you
know, this is the way forward.
- Yeah, it's a good question
because, you know, when we
started Rambler in 2021,
like, you know, there were
no vision language models.
Like, we've been going through, you know,
development cycles and research cycles.
I've never experienced anything
even remotely like that,
and now we are at a stage
where literally with a
relatively small model,
7 billion parameters that you
can run on an edge device,
you know, you can actually
extract granular details
from, you know, how humans
interact with the world,
how robots interact with the world.
It's, you know, I can't really pinpoint
what that like wow moment was
where I was like, oh my God,
this is like we are heading into a future
that we don't really understand
how systems that understand our world
can actually start
supporting us, helping us,
and not just during work hours,
but also throughout our
day-to-day lives, right?
Like, if you think of the next
generation consumer devices,
we see kind of the first adoption
with the Meta Ray-Ban 3
and Meta Ray-Ban 3 display,
and now they're, you know,
pretty much every consumer
electronics provider
is coming out with a new device.
We're also seeing a lot more cameras
deployed out there, right?
But like these systems,
they need to be able to support you
throughout your day to day,
which means it's a very heavy workload
like processing frames.
Unfortunately, we can't
fit it on just CPU.
That requires, you know,
pretty powerful GPUs out there,
and I'm really excited
about the future and what it's bringing,
and, you know, companies like AMD
have really unlocked that space.
Also, you know, bringing physical AI
really into the real
world where it matters,
and yeah, I'm very excited about that.
- I think that that is one of the reasons
why, like, when AMD was
designing the hardware, you know,
specifications for like what to go after,
capacity and bandwidth are huge, right?
Obviously computational
flops are important,
but we need to be able to
consume like data at the scale.
So if you look at, you know,
generation over generation,
we've consistently had leadership
in terms of, you know, 288 gigs of HBM,
like a year or two before
competition shows up, right?
So if you have those ideas
on like what to build,
you know, AMD definitely has
a good hardware footprint,
and on the software side
too, we are, you know,
we wanna make it very seamless.
So, you know, we understand
the incumbent ecosystem
so if you've played with
it, we wanna make sure
that the transition to
evaluating AMD is zero friction.
Just like we've done on the CPUs,
on the GPUs to like, no code changes,
you should be able to run on AMD hardware.
So I think this is good.
So, you know, I wanna
switch it up a little bit
and let's just see because we
have vision language models,
we have enterprise AI,
we have biology and AI.
Like hypothetically, if
we were all brainstorming
to start a company, what would we build,
like the four of us?
Like, I mean, let's say I'm
the guy who's gonna go sell it.
So let's leave me out of the way.
I'll give you the compute.
What will the three of you want to build
given, you know, biology, enterprise,
vision language models?
I know it's a idea generation question.
- I can start.
- Yeah.
- Well, a real time world model.
That's, I think, you know, this
will unlock a lot out there
because we're still in
that world where, you know,
for us to be able to analyze
video streams accurately,
we need to go through a lot
of fine tuning and training
on domain-specific data.
There's definitely, you know,
foundation models were
trained on all of the data
that they could get their
hands on in the internet,
which is not really representative
of what you encounter in
the real world usually.
So I'm really excited
about the opportunity around world models
and, you know, currently there.
- Well, but you have to make sure
Arjun has something to do, right?
- Well, I'm pretty sure biology-
- You're like, I'm gonna do world models,
but what does the biology guy do?
- But that's like, you know, I mean,
a world model by definition
should encompass it all, right?
It should have a deep
understanding of physics.
- Maybe it's a world model
where you have a robot that's, you know?
- Exactly.
Yeah, maybe Arjun, you can take that idea,
and now I throw the ball over to you.
- I would be very excited
about, you know, AI scientists.
I was joking with a colleague of mine.
Well, maybe joking.
You know, the university
should just be buying
fields of warehouse space
to put a bunch of AI, you know, scientists
to do all the science.
- Isn't that what the genesis or something
that the Trump, the White House?
- Yeah, I think, and there
are many other, you know,
science organizations who are interested
in this sort of vision,
but I think, you know,
the key thing is to really, like,
if we want to turn it into a
reinforcement learning problem,
I think that we need
to have robots somehow,
and, you know, I think the state of that
is still kinda more here than here,
but I think using things like world models
obviously would make a huge difference.
The potential there is super exciting,
and I think also, you
know, being able to handle
also all of the data that's out there
in the form of scientific literature
and all this knowledge
that we spent, you know,
hundreds of years and they're
trapped in these ancient,
you know, photocopies of a
fax of a PDF or something.
Being able to extract all of
that and use it in some way
I think would be very exciting.
- Yeah, that was actually
what I was getting to.
I'll be the plumber.
(panelists laugh)
Because like, typically, but I think
what you touched on earlier
is like very important.
A lot of times, really
mission critical information
is not in public.
It is like, you know, whether it's like
a research institution's
proprietary reports
or it's, you know, companies
like corporate business knowledge,
those are not searchable online.
So a lot of times when we are launching
these big, you know,
groundbreaking initiatives,
it requires tapping into
some triple knowledge
that is in the form of
documents a lot of time,
whether that's like physical documents,
digitized document doesn't really matter.
But because these are proprietary,
a lot of time this hasn't been digitized.
So we do this a lot with
like research institutions,
we actually did this with one MPO
that reports on the carbon
emission reports across the globe
and they have like years of reports
that is extremely complicated,
and we just, you know,
unlocked the entire reports
that they had it in depository
and that enabled them
to evaluate all the monitoring progress,
what are the trends that they
haven't been able to monitor
when this information was
not easily searchable.
So I think wherever I go,
plumber is needed everywhere
so happy to collaborate.
- All right, I think we are
coming up on with an idea.
So we're gonna build a AI scientist robot
that is powered by the
vision language models
to take us through the
libraries that can do the OCR,
read all the PDFs that you referenced,
and make biological discoveries.
Okay, good, let's go get some funding.
- Any VCs in the audience?
- Just use AMD hardware, that's all.
Okay, that is fun, and I think
that is indicative of like,
the transformative, you know,
effect that AI is having, right?
I think of it almost similar
to like electricity, right?
Like yeah, we discovered
electricity, we lit up a bulb,
but now it's like, oh, I can run a motor,
I can power an engine, I
can get transportation.
I can, you know, there are
like so many other pieces of it
that electricity, you know, unlocked,
and I think of like these
core foundational models
and LLMs, and VLMs also.
Enabling that level of like unlock
that we are still at the
early stages of like,
trying to understand and reason with.
So that's super exciting.
So are there places where
you think we are not...
There are places where you
think we should be applying AI
and we haven't yet unlocked a whole area
of like, you know, like DNA sequencing
or, you know, some areas that you think
is underrepresented with AI
so that somebody else can go
start a company right now.
But thoughts on areas underrepresented?
- Oh man, you should
start with these guys.
- Okay. (laughs)
- I feel like walked around
the hall and I'm like,
well, pretty much every
area is represented.
- What do you think, Roman?
I can't really pinpoint
a specific vertical
because we are still at
that stage where, you know,
we haven't even, like,
most companies out there
are not really using advanced AI
in their day to day processes.
So I feel like we are
still at the very beginning
of the cycle of adapting AI
and figuring out, you know,
how it can change the way we do things.
- Right.
- Hard to tell.
I'm passing it on.
- Well, I think physical AI
is obvious the next hot topic.
That one thing that,
you know, it's, again,
I'm coming from a data and, you know,
the foundation point of view,
we've collected all these
like text like language-based,
text-based data across, you
know, scrapping entire internet.
But for the physical AI,
basically how do we collect
the real human interaction data
for training a really strong work model
or in a physical model?
And I know there are a lot of startups
who are doing that at a
very early stage, but like,
if one can figure out
how to systematically
collect these data points,
for example, like how a human, you know,
sweep the floor when there is a corner
that's really hard to get,
like, robot's not gonna,
I mean, it's not gonna figure that out,
but like if someone's gonna actually like,
put a bunch of like stuff on their hand
and like, you know, collect that data,
like, those kind of things,
I think there's a big, big market there
and that hasn't been tapped
and I know like we are
trying to use the robotics
to collect that data.
So I think there's a
lot of creative thinking
going around in the industry, but yeah,
overall I think if we can figure that out,
we can build a lot better model
'cause garbage in, garbage out.
So I think the data collection site
will be the next really hot topic.
- Don't look any further.
- There we go.
- This is at the core of what we're doing.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- But that is a very
good point, and in fact,
just a few weeks ago we
had like John Carmack
trying out like the RYZEN Max
395, the strict halo product.
He has a reinforcement
learning based AGI company,
which is basically trying
to do exactly that.
It's like you have a reinforcement
learning based method
to quickly learn how to
get to that corner, right?
And then you have a reward system,
and there are companies built
just to streamline the
reward system, right?
but when do you know, like,
just the reward itself is like,
okay, this is right, this is wrong, right?
Or it's trending towards
right, trending towards wrong.
So there's a lot of that kind
of innovation that's ongoing.
And I think, you know,
reinforcement learning itself
is another way that
will help us, you know,
get to the basics of like,
how we learn how to walk or talk, right?
It's a, you know, natural phenomena
that we haven't yet
unlocked in terms of AI.
I do think AI, my
personal opinion is like,
on that same topic, AI will
kind of make its way into things
that we don't even know as AI.
It's like just indistinguishable
and we are just like,
oh wow, now I can do that, right?
And then suddenly it's
like that, you know,
flight rebooking example that I use,
and then it unlocks for
huge amounts of people
that are not necessarily
thinking of it as AI, right?
Like, they're just thinking of it as like,
something that enhances their life, right?
So I think it's incredibly exciting
to be at that stage of like revolution.
So, you know, let's switch gears
just in terms of like
actual how your current,
we talked about infrastructure.
Are there other thoughts in terms of like,
how do you make it, make
your companies, you know,
operate in an AI era?
Like, what is important for you
to be competitive, you know,
but at the same time do the
research that you have to do,
make sure you're, you know,
targeting a market that's moving so fast.
Any thoughts that, you know,
you want to share just in general
about like how you as a
company approach that?
- I can start.
Yeah, yeah, so one thing that's, you know,
I think I haven't shared this
context earlier, but Upstage,
our LLM we are positioning our LLM
as a sovereign AI of Korea.
So there's a very big like,
data sovereignty concept
that is core of our identity.
When we approach AI as really
a strong strategic asset
that we should be able
to control and manage,
not just the performance of a
single infrastructure provider
is good enough.
We need to be able to diversify
just like how we are going multi-cloud.
Like, a lot of enterprises are, you know,
tapping into multi-cloud.
So for the stability of the system,
and I think when we approach
this AI infrastructure,
we're thinking the same that
we are building that AI model,
that our vision is this
is going to empower Korea
to the next level,
and we want to be that
AI layer for our economy.
Then we need to think
about how do we make sure
that we build the stability in
terms of the infrastructure?
So, you know, we wanted to
make sure AMD is in the mix,
all the other GPU
providers are in the mix.
So all the risks are hedged, and frankly,
like, we initially thought
that it will be a
difficult transition for us
to go from one to another,
but I think there has been
enough improvement in the system
that we can actually easily port over
and make sure things are compatible,
which our engineers are very
happy when we did a pilot.
So for us, when we think about, you know,
how we make sure we build
the most compelling AI
layer for the country,
we think about the hardware sovereignty,
the data sovereignty,
and all the training method
and the approach that we are taking
to make sure that what
we build is competitive
but also authentic.
So if there's any random variables
happened in a macro level, micro level,
we're able to hedge the risk.
- Nice.
That's great to hear that, you know,
porting to AMD was seamless
because if it isn't,
that's my problem to let you know,
You can email me and be like,
Anush, we need this fixed
and we'll make sure it's fixed.
But that's great.
Arjun, any thoughts from your side?
- Yeah, I mean, for us, you know,
and our team is very diverse.
I mean, because we've got, you know,
we've got software engineers,
we have computational
biologists, which are, you know,
bioinformatics people who are taking in
the raw sequencing data and, you know,
turning that into things
that we could put into
machine learning models.
We have a huge experimental team
that's, you know,
actually making this data.
For us, what that means
in terms of infrastructure
is we need to have
infrastructure like AWS and AMD
that is very flexible and seamless.
So that we're, you know, our
resources are stretched thin,
we have so many different
people doing different things.
They need things to just work,
and they need to just work
out of the box seamlessly
so we're not spending a lot of time,
you know, handling all of
that, all of those details,
and rather people are focusing
on where they have their main
sort of competence and talent.
So yeah, I would say, you
know, along those lines,
one of the things that's been great
about working with AMD
is really, you know,
we feel like we found a
partner not so much a vendor.
So we found people that will
help us handle those details
when they come up so that again,
we can focus on what we need to do
rather than worrying about
things that we're not experts in.
- No, that's great to hear.
I think from an AMD
ethos standpoint, right?
Like, one of the things
that I really enjoy at AMD
is that it's a open ecosystem
and it's open source obviously, right?
At a technical level,
going back to your thing on sovereign AI,
it can be air gapped, but
every line of code is like,
you can build it and you own it
and so you know what's in there.
So it gives you, you know,
peace of mind saying,
yes, this is ours, and
ours as a collective
in terms of like how we enable you.
But then ours as in like, your deployment,
it's your deployment. Like, we
want to enable you to do that
and we want you to be
able to like build on it
and have your proprietary IP
and your things in a safe environment
that you're able to
like, verify and validate
without, you know, some binary blobs
that we can throw around
that may not necessarily provide that.
But yeah, I think the open ecosystem
and the important point of
just working is another piece
that we take very seriously,
and I do like how you put it.
We do see, you know,
everyone as like partners
and it's not just like, hey, buy our GPU
and go download something
and go do something, right?
You know, I personally
have seen deployments
in, you know, go from like,
hey, let's have a discussion
on how we could do this
to, in like, you know,
a month or two they're deployed at scale
in tens of thousands of
GPUs and it's just working
is amazing to see.
So it's great to see that.
But Roman, I wouldn't want
you to miss your flight.
- No, go for it.
It's all good.
- But we'd love to hear any, you know,
any final thoughts from you.
We'll keep them on stage
for a little bit longer
so that you can peel off
whenever you're ready.
- No, I think those are
all very important points
that you guys made,
and I guess I wanna put
one additional focus point on there,
and this is kind of, we are at a point
where, you know, open data sets
become more and more important,
and when I say open data sets,
I'm not talking about some
random research dataset.
I'm talking about high quality data sets
that actually bring the models
from where they are today
to the next level
because we are at a point
where it's really about domain specificity
and understanding environments
on a more granular basis.
It's tough, right?
Because certainly in the
industrial sector in that data,
there's a lot of proprietary information.
So there's of course
not a lot of willingness
to share that data with
the wider community,
but it's starting to stall the progress
that we make on these
models and the capabilities,
the generalization
capabilities of these models.
So at Rambler, we are
kind of counteracting that
by working on an open source data set.
Really high quality
with regards to the
annotations and labels,
but of course we are, you
know, small fish, right?
At the end of the day.
So for the community to be willing
to start contributing to that
pool of data that can be used,
and maybe even a little bit outside
of just a traditional research community.
I think that will be critical
to unlock the next
generation of these models.
- Yeah, I do think, you
know, good data sets,
good open source models also.
- Correct.
- That are good baselines
so that you can still
build your, you know,
proprietary, you know,
like modified version of it
that solves a specific use case, right?
We want you to have the
ability to build on top of it,
but at the same time, this
gives you a good baseline
that is like, oh, this is
what GPT assist does, right?
Or this is what Llama does,
and then the data sets that
they used for those training,
you know, that also makes it powerful.
So to make it available, you know,
for the open community to innovate
and move the ball forward.
Cool.
So I think, you know, what I'd like
to kind of like bring the thoughts back,
and then we'll have some,
you know, time for Q&A
if folks have Q&A, but, you know,
I think it's super exciting
to have everyone here,
you know, talk about
different parts of AI, right?
Like, they're almost like, you know,
before getting on stage,
it's like people here may not realize
how diverse it is, right?
And when you go to the expo flow,
it's even like 10 X more diverse.
But, you know, from an AMD
standpoint, we wanna make sure
that you have choice in terms of hardware,
you have freedom in terms of the software,
and then you have like a partner
in terms of the ecosystem.
So that we want to walk
that last mile of AI
so that you can then bring value
to each of the verticals
that you are going after.
While we obviously are,
you know, quarterbacking
and would love to see you
all succeed in that front,
and it doesn't necessarily mean
that we want to take, you know,
it's not a vertically integrated thing
to have a combination of
like Bio Nemo for you,
or, you know, we are not
very prescriptive that way.
We think of it as an open ecosystem
where you should have the tools needed
and the tools we will definitely provide.
So that you can do the best
work that you can for that.
Any last thoughts from you guys
before we see if there are any questions?
Roman?
- No, I think you hit
the nail on the head.
I think you fulfill a very important role
also on the tool side to
enable companies out there
to focus on, you know,
building these more
domain-specific solutions
and, you know, you doing
some of the groundwork.
I think this is really the enabling factor
also for new startups that come out
that don't have the manpower,
the budget to build-
- All the tools.
- All the tools around
it, all the agent stacks,
all the, you know, safety
security protocols.
You can go down the list of things
that you need in a large scale deployment.
So thank you for putting in the hard work.
- Kasey?
- Yeah, I think it's related
to what the earlier point here
that I just want to, I know
they're not in this room,
but shout out to the AMD Ventures team.
It was incredible working
with the venture side.
We had, you know, before we're still
in the process of making it,
but before when we were
very small, you know,
when we were just getting started,
AMD believed in our vision,
supported our vision,
and, you know, decided to be the partner
and sponsor of our journey,
and all the technical
support, all the, you know,
leadership support has
been just incredible,
and, you know, anytime
AMD's there will be there
and, you know, really thankful
for the support that you've shown, yeah.
- Arjun, any final thoughts?
- I would just echo the same
thing is that, you know,
it's been wonderful to work with you guys,
and, you know, hope it continues
for foreseeable future.
- We will make sure it continues,
and looking forward to
making you all successful.
If there are any questions,
happy to take, you know,
a couple of questions.
- I'm very sorry.
- Thank you.
Don't miss your flight.
(attendees applaud)